what do I think about MC ends I'm going
to answer that question in today's
episode of lunch and earn hey guys
greeting from Hollywood California I
recently asked a question for one of my
YouTube fans love you guys the yuck
mouth family who wanted to know about
MCNS they wrote in to say here's a topic
you should talk about I've never heard
so much feedback positive negative about
this topic is it worth having and
network for your channel so much hater
on the topic people argue the fact that
networks don't do nothin but take your
money as for me I look at as agents in
Hollywood they're going to give you as
much attention as much money as you
bring in for them I'm network by tgn a
gaming community but thinking of
applying for someone else since i have
no contract policy i was approached by
mahkumaat but i know there's a
seven-year contract and when you leave
they keep your channel give us your
thoughts on the good and the bad so as a
general principle I'm a big fan of
surrounding yourself with people who
complement your weaknesses and you have
in the self-awareness to know what
you're good at and what you could need
some help with and so applying that to
MC ends I'd be thinking do you have the
business skills to go out and get the
partnerships and get the advertising
revenue and build up your channel and do
the marketing or do you just want to be
a gamer I'll share my personal opinions
and this is just highly personal and
hopefully that helps you in your
decision making for me I am NOT with an
MCN and I don't see myself going there
anytime soon one of the big reasons is I
don't see that as a huge weakness for me
I'm good at the business stuff right I
like closing brand deals i'm good at the
marketing the promotion and that's not
kind of being arrogant that's just
understanding what I'm good at and what
I'm not good at and so I don't see them
be able to provide a lot of value to me
and so that's why I haven't signed up
with anybody I've been approached by a
ton of them the big ones small ones but
I haven't gone with anybody mostly for
that reason the other thing I'd be
thinking about is a lot of these guys
have
a hard time delivering value to the
small players right if you have a
million subscribers plus then it's easy
right then you get the dedicated
managers and the brands are interested
in you where a lot of the MC ends they
have a hard time delivering value to
this little guy right they can assign
you a dedicated manager so they're
trying to give you resources on mass or
trying to give you royalty free music
they're trying to give you a lot of
stuff that's kind of easy to give to
anybody but that's why a lot of people
complain about the value because they're
not getting personal attention and it
makes sense because the MCNS aren't
making enough off of you yet to be able
to give you that more personalized
attention so that's why you see a lot of
the haters around the MC ends one last
thing that I would add to this is I see
a lot of change that's going to happen
in the industry one of the reasons why
you know I'm hesitant to buy a tesla car
is because i feel like the technology is
going to be changing so much you never
want to go and buy the newest computer
because you're paying a premium price
for it and the technology changes so
quickly where I feel like the YouTube
space and the MCNS are so new that a lot
is going to change in the next couple
years in the next 12 months next 24
months and if you're there signing up
with the wrong MCN and there they're
locking you in for seven years and
they're not the ones that keep up with
the trends and you're going to be left
behind and you have no control over it I
hate losing control over decisions that
impact my business especially once if
you're trying to go all-in on youtube
and make it a full time income so I mean
those are my reasons I'm not I
and I don't see myself signing up at any
point with an MCN but who knows things
may change your grievance may change the
marketplace may change to give you
feedback and advice in the most
practical way possible I would summarize
by saying if you feel like the business
side is not something you're good at not
something that you want to be good at
and learn and you want to focus on your
niche gaming or otherwise then it might
be worth looking at an MCN I would look
at a company where you still have some
kind of control where you have some kind
of out clause when you're not tied in
for years and years and years and years
because if you blow up and make it big
and you want to make this a full time
income I would hate to have given up
control to somebody else my throat is
very dry I've talked a lot it is
insanely hot today in Hollywood so I'm
going to end it there thank you guys for
watching I'm curious to know your
experiences using MCNS are you with one
do you like it or not pros and cons
leave in the comments below and I'm
going to join the discussion thank you
guys continue to believe and I'll see
you soon